what does you understand it is their
problem with you competing I'm legally a
medically female but the people who
oppose my existence still want to think
of me as male they use the language of
that I'm a man and so there's this
stereotype that men are always stronger
than women and so if you think of trans
women as men then you think there's an
unfair advantage
spoole is a human right just explain
what that means for you we care about
the Olympics we care about our favorite
soccer
I'm sorry Football Club we care about
the Rugby World Cup we care about sport
it is central to society so if you want
to say well I believe you're a woman for
all of society except this massive
central part that is sport then that's
not fair so fairness is the inclusion of
trans women do you think you'd have been
a world champion cyclist if you hadn't
transitioned I don't think I am a world
champion because I'm a trans woman I put
in the work and again we have to
remember I lose most of my races I've
lost against the specific sis women
complaining about me being unfair the
men's hundred meter record is nine point
five eight seconds the women's is ten
point four nine seconds there is an
undisputable advantage for four men in
sport isn't there we talk about men
being faster than women we have to be
very careful what we're talking about so
the example you gave was at the most
faith and strength sports they have a
ten 10 percent 12 percent advantage in
most scientific opinions at the elite
level right so when we look at the very
best athletes in men and women you see
this roughly 10 to 12 percent gap but if
we're talking about like the average man
no that's what we're talking about the
IFC what's hooking about the elite level
only of course if you look within a
single sex event the difference between
1st and 8th is very large and the
difference between first and 1st between
sexes is often smaller than the
difference between 1st and 8th within a
sex so by that logic would you not have
male or female
categories whatsoever I think that's a
great question I think that's a
different question so I think it's not
fair to trans people to say well in
order to fix whether to include you in
sport let's just radically shift how we
do sport the IOC has no appetite for
that at the moment they are fully
committed to only to sex categories of
sport a study by the the Swedish
University the Karolinska Institute
which I know you've read closely it does
say that there's very limited change in
thigh strength 12 months after
transitioning and taking testosterone
suppressants high strength as you know
more than anyone else obviously a huge
thing particularly in in sport
particularly in track cycling do you
accept that there there may still be an
advantage is it possible yes however the
range of body sizes and strength levels
within a sport you can be successful
with massively different body
compositions even within my sport so
again a British example would be
Victoria Pendleton teeny-tiny skinny
legs best in the world
if Chris Hoy was to transition a
master's level if he was to take
testosterone suppressants foot for 12
months and then compete at masters level
against Victoria Pendleton he would beat
Victoria Pendleton she would beat
Victoria Pendleton would Chris we don't
actually know that again we are making
this massive assumption but also fair
assumption tonight I don't you know we
we haven't seen this in the rest of
sport so again trans women have been
allowed to openly compete since 2004
since the 2004 Olympics since the 2016
Olympics you didn't require genital
surgery and we didn't see a single trans
person so it was already the case that
an unscrupulous country could have taken
someone like Chris Hoy and met the
testosterone policy gave him a passport
for female and said off you go to Rio
didn't happen so we've already had two
Olympic cycles where this could have
happened and it didn't so when you ask
me well here's this potential case what
should we do now with real people based
on this potential fantasy case that is
not how human rights work if this bigger
than than sport is this about it more
important that the trans women feel that
they're included than to maintain a
category within sport I think you're
you're asking me is like trans women
inclusion more important than the
fairness in sport but again my point is
that trans inclusion is fairness it is
unfair to exclude legal and medical
women trans women from women's sport or
part of society so this is much bigger
than sport in that it's it's the proxy
for all of trans inclusion in society
talk of of bathrooms has shifted into
sport by people who don't care about
sport so I think it's clear that this
issue is bigger than sport